hello everyone lastly one chip is
definitely one of my favorite players
and there are more incredible stories
about Chucky than about any other chess
player in general and this game is from
1991 linear RS tournament in Spain it
was the strongest tournament ever held
to that date and it featured 14 of the
strongest players players in the world
world champion Garry Kasparov was their
former world champion Anatoly Karpov was
there you had Anand billiards kill you
boy which is super all the strongest
players in the world were there and
lastly when she also played this
tournament and vastly one she actually
won this tournament half a point ahead
of Garry Kasparov and this is a round
one of the tournament were vastly much
is facing Garry Kasparov and this is
well one of the most amazing games as
well it contradicts pretty much
everything you know about chess and it
does take a genius like you want you to
play a game like this against the world
champion as well yeah you'll just have
to see it so if I jus kiss the white and
the Garry Kasparov is black we have E
for c5 the Sicilian defence Knight to f3
d6 and here it won't replace Bishop to
b5 with Czech as he probably didn't want
to go for d4 and allow Kasparov to go
for his famous night off we have a
Knight to d7
we have d4 Knight to f6 events from
castles seek a person d4 and now Queen
captures on d4 and this is a beautiful
centralizing move by von Schuch as
Kasparov did choose to develop his B
night on d7 so now there's no Knight to
c6 move to kick the Queen out of d4 we
have a six and here Kasparov is well he
won't see one trip to state his purpose
as what's he going to do with the bishop
and this is the the first big surprise
of the game eventual place Bishop
capture 77 voluntarily given up his own
Bishop and allowing as part of to help
the bishop there we should capture 77
and now well here you could go for the
maraca sabayon with c4 and continuing
the game in that fashion but even Chuck
has a different idea she plays Bishop to
G
five and here as part of well repeats
his action from the queenside he plays
h6 now and this is the second great
surprise of the game as you want to
place Bishop captures on f6 giving up
both of his bishops and now he will have
two knights against two bishops and this
would this will this would be considered
crazy you know to give this kind of an
advantage to the world champion but as
you'll see charkie the genius makes it
work fantastically so okay we have G
captures on f6 and now as part of even
has the open G file to attack this this
poor King and g1 c4 we have e 6 and
Knight to c3 rook the c8 and here event
took place King to H 1 so he is
preparing for Kasparov was roof to g8 so
he will have time to defend as part of
place h5 going for the attack but he
want to completely ignores this as he
does have two knights against two
bishops and he wants to cramp the
position as much as possible we are a 4h
4-bike as part of going to place h3 to
stop any h3 ideas by Casper on himself
Bishop to e7 and now before we have a 5
and V 5 and as you see even though
because part of does have the two
bishops they are still occupying d7 and
a seven and well even choke isn't really
feeling their influence Queen to c7
divided by cos part of and the Knights
the d2 now defending that c4 pawn and
Queen to c5 casparo wants to exchange
Queens a bunch of the clients between d3
as as is the general rule in chess when
you when you control more space you
usually don't want to exchange Queens or
even minor pieces Rock the g8 by
Kasparov and rook 81 here we have Queen
to g5 now threatening Queen captures and
g2 with checkmate but defending this is
pretty simple root 2 G 1 we have Queen
to f4 Becker's pair of attacking this F
do pawn and now you want to place rook e
to F 1 and this is a very weird
both constellation as you
I mean there's a rockin f1 and g1 this
is it's not it's not the usual set up
for for for the for the side defending
we have be 6 by Kasparov and here
here comes in logic is an amazing idea
he plays Knight to e2 and he wants to
kick the Queen out of f-4s power plays
Queen to h6 and this is well definitely
the best more the game even took breaks
off in the position with c5 and this is
a temporary pawn sacrifice but actually
what this is doing avenge piece well
vacating the c-4 square for this night
on d2 Kasparov plays rook captures on c5
and we have nice to see for by event
choke and now he can capture on here on
d6 with check but even even a greater
threat is night capture some b6 and
creating a passed pawn here and this is
a wall even the engine is giving white
the edge here and the engine is actually
suggesting that the black rook should
capture the knight on c4 but Kasparov
played King to f8 as well he's expecting
United captures and b6 so he has this eh
were available for his Bishop so we have
Knight capture some b6 attacking the
bishop and Bishop d8 and now Kasparov
the bishop pair is doing even less we
have f4 by von Schuch and now F 5 by
Kasparov where he captures an f5 rook
captures on f5 and I wrote the c1 well
in magic is ready to infiltrate with the
rook using the C file to the last rank
or maybe even the seventh rank depending
on what Kasparov place we have king to
g7 now making room for Ace King and also
the King will be much safer here and
here another brilliant move by vine
choke he plays G for kicking the rook
out of f5 and also preparing to push his
pawns and the idea is that H captors and
g3 is impossible if H captors and g3
then Queen captures and g3 would check
if the King moves the Queen will grab
the rock and g8 and
good if Casper would try to block this
with quinta g6 don't simply Quintus III
check and Caspar loses the Queen
so after G for a spiral plate worked the
c5 we have rook captures and c5 by mine
truly captures on c5 and on Knight to c8
and well as you see the knight is
attacking this Bishop on e7 and also
Kasparov has to has to have in mind this
be pawn as b6 b7 and b8 are very close
he plays Bishop to f8 defending and now
look at this bishop pair I mean this is
the worst bishop pair probably in in
history of chess we have Queen to d8 now
again attacking this Bishop even though
he's an da ta it is still being attacked
and here as part of tries one more idea
he plays Queen to g6 he wants eventual
to capture this Bishop on e8 as he's
hoping for Queen captures an e 8 and now
Queen to d3 attacking this night and e2
and also threatening to capture on h3 so
after a move like rope 2g to defending
the knight wing captures an h3 with
check King to g1 now Queen to III with
check pink to f1 and Casper would
actually have decent chances in this
position as well this H pawn is ready to
go down the board and also the C pawn is
ready to go down the board so he would
have some chances here but after this
Queen to g6 six move event Chuck doesn't
allow this he plays f5 and Casper can't
really capture the pawn as pawn captures
pawn captures
spiral loses the Queen so after this f5
move Kasparov played Queen to h6 now
again his he has some ideas of Queen to
e3 but if I took steel doesn't capture
the bishop on e8 he plays g5 of course
we have Queen to h5 and now isn't the
finisher rook the g4 he doesn't let the
Queen into the game and Kasparov destroy
it captures an f5 attacking the rook but
here Evon took simple plays Knight to f4
with the tempo on the Queen and in this
position because part of could have
easily
resigned but he played it played a
couple of more moves we have a queen to
h8 and look at Kasparov speices the
bishop pair on EI tanned FA to the rook
on on g8 behind the king on g7 and the
Queen and h8 this is this is beautiful
this is beautiful a beautiful
accomplished friend by von Schuch
he plays Queen to f6 with check came to
h7 and now the simple rook to age for
checking checking the king and whatever
black plays it's checkmate next move
even though the only movies
well Bishop to h6 and now simply rook
captures on h6 is checkmate or Queen
captures and h6 doesn't even matter
but after Luke captures on h4 Kasparov
resigned the game and I mean this is a
this was Kasparov probably in his prime
this is 1991 Kasparov and they want to
destroyed him and in the first round and
won the tournament half a point ahead of
Kasparov and well a lot of people say
that even shook when even shook is
feeling good when in magic is in top
form
there is no chess player in the world
that can that can play a game against
the von Schuch it doesn't matter the
time format as this game was played in
1991 and this is this is how I want to
destroy the world champion Garry
Kasparov but even last year I was the
world blitz and rapid championship in
Doha and eventually eventually defeated
Magnus Carlsen first in rapid and then
in blitz so 25 years after this game
against Kasparov event you can still
defeat the world champion twice in a row
so there definitely definitely quite a
guy and yeah this is this is this is the
beauty this is the avengers immortal and
I do hope you enjoyed it I mean I I
enjoy it every time I see it and I would
like to thank Paul apply for a
contribution to my channel I really
appreciate it thank you sir and yeah
thank you all for watching as usual you
can check to my previous videos here and
I will see you soon